en este vídeo vamos a platicar acerca de
puntos sobre bisectriz es pero antes de
eso quiero asegurarme que entendamos a
qué me refiero cuando hablo acerca de la
distancia de un punto a una recta
entonces déjame poner por ahí un punto y
por acá vamos a poner la recta definida
por los puntos b y c bueno si tuviera
cualquier otro punto d entonces es muy
fácil hablar de la distancia de aa de
simplemente es la longitud del segmento
que los une pero si tenemos aquí toda
una recta bc hay varios segmentos hay
varios segmentos que unen con la recta
por ejemplo estoy acá o este de acá o
este de acá y todos esos tienen
longitudes diferentes entonces tenemos
todos tenemos que ser todavía más
específicos para definir la distancia de
la recta y justo lo que vamos a hacer es
tomarnos la distancia al punto más
cercano aa que esté en la recta abc y
ese punto se construye trazando la
perpendicular de a abc vale entonces es
un punto de por aquí un punto de por
aquí tal que los ángulos
y adba son de 90 grados y para pensar un
poquito en por qué este punto es el que
hace la distancia más corta lo que
podemos hacer es trazar cualquier otro
punto donde sea puede ser para allá o
para allá podemos poner ahí y trazar hay
con eso se forma un triángulo rectángulo
de dónde es la hipotenusa y por lo tanto
es el lado más largo en particular le
gana a ade y bueno para pensar esto de
que la hipotenusa le gana a cualquiera
de los lados o para justificarlo podemos
hacer es usar el teorema de pitágoras
porque hay al cuadrado es de al cuadrado
más d al cuadrado y entonces a él le
gana a andy vale bueno espero que eso
justifique un poco porque la distancia
más corta se obtiene bajando una
perpendicular bueno entonces es la
distancia de un punto a una recta
ahora vamos a platicar un poco acerca de
bisectriz es de un ángulo entonces
déjame trazar por aquí una
un ángulo
vamos a pensar que este se llama a que
se llama be y este se llama c entonces
es el ángulo abc y vamos a trazar la
bisectriz la bisectriz es una recta o
segmento o rayo lo puedes pensar como
sea que corta este ángulo a la mitad es
decir es un rayo si quieres que diseca
el ángulo es es un rayo tal que si aquí
ponemos un punto de entonces tenemos que
el ángulo ave de ave de mide lo mismo
que el ángulo cp de cbd vale entonces
voy a ponerlo por acá tenemos que el
ángulo el ángulo a bbb es congruente al
ángulo cvd al ángulo se ve de y en este
caso decimos que vd
si quieres lo podemos poner como rayo vd
biseca y seca al ángulo
abc a bs muy bien ahora la razón por la
cual empecé a hablando de de distancia
de un punto a una recta es la siguiente
en este vídeo vamos a mostrar que
cualquier punto sobre la bisectriz s
instante de estos dos lados de vea y de
veces y también vamos a probar el
regreso vamos a ver que si tenemos un
punto que es equidistante debe a bbc
entonces ese punto cae sobre la
bisectriz bueno pues vamos a empezar
probando lo primero que dije es decir
vamos a tomar un punto por aquí un punto
e íbamos a mostrar que este punto es
equidistante de vea y dbc o sea que
tiene la misma distancia hacia estas dos
rectas
bueno pues justo para tener la distancia
del punto a las rectas lo que tenemos
que hacer es bajar perpendiculares hacia
las dos rectas déjame ponerle que aquí
el punto al que baja se llama efe y aquí
al punto al que baja se llama g bueno
entonces lo que queremos probar es que
el f es igual a eje que la distancia de
este punto esta recta es la misma que el
punto a la recta de acá y para hacer eso
vamos a utilizar los triángulos gm y fbi
observemos que son triángulos ambos
rectángulos el ángulo bg y el pf son
ángulos rectos y además que comparten el
ángulo heavy
porque gm
igual a efe ya que está sobre la
bisectriz de esta forma el tercer ángulo
también tiene que ser igual este de acá
también es igual a este de acá y así
podemos aplicarles el criterio ángulo
lado a ángulo porque también comparten
este segmento el segmento b entonces lo
voy a escribir por acá esto es igual a
éste entonces tenemos que el triángulo
gbm gbm es congruente al triángulo fbi
al triángulo
efe y como son triángulos congruentes
entonces sus partes correspondientes
también son congruentes y de aquí
podemos concluir que f
efe es igual a g
otra forma de escribirlo es que efe así
con barrita es congruente para el
segmento es congruente al segmento de
acá son dos formas de escribir
exactamente lo mismo pero bueno eso es
justo lo que queríamos mostrar o sea
esto de aquí nos dice que esta longitud
es igual a esta longitud y el punto y
entonces el punto es equidistante debe a
bbc muy bien ahora lo que vamos a hacer
es probar el regreso es decir ahora nos
vamos a tomar un punto equidistante a
los dos lados y vamos a ver que
pertenece a la bisectriz para eso déjame
tomarme otra vez un ángulo vamos a poner
otra vez un poco de nombres aquí va a
estar a por acabe por acá va estar c c
vale y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
tomar un punto equidistante a vea y abc
entonces va a estar bueno o sea tiene
que ser algo más o menos de este estilo
vamos a llamarle el punto
ok entonces ese punto es equidistante
al bajar la perpendicular para acá mide
lo mismo que al bajar la perpendicular
para acá ok y lo que nos gustaría ver es
que ese punto cae sobre la bisectriz de
abc entonces déjame déjame trazar este
rayo el bm el bm para otra vez formar
triángulos y ver que podemos encontrar
va bueno vamos a llamar a este punto de
aquí
efe a este punto de acá g
bueno entonces tenemos los triángulos
efe
estos dos triángulos pues ya tienen
varias cosas en común verdad como
tomamos el punto que tenemos que eje es
igual a efe porque el punto es
equidistante de ambas rectas además
tenemos que tienen pues estoy acá en
común verdad el segmento b lo voy a
marcar así y finalmente pues vemos
démonos cuenta que tienen este ángulo
recto aquí entonces los dos son ángulos
son triángulos rectángulos donde tienen
la hipotenusa en común y uno de los
lados en común entonces el tercer lado
como está dado por el teorema de
pitágoras también tiene que ser el mismo
va entonces este de acá es igual a este
de acá son segmentos congruentes bf es
igual a bg otra vez son triángulos
rectángulos tienen la misma hipotenusa y
un mismo lado el tercer lado está dado
por el teorema de pitágoras restando al
cuadrado de este del cuadrado de estoy
sacando raíz pero como esta longitud es
igual a sí misma y esta es igual a ésta
entonces esta de acá va a ser igual a
esta de acá bueno entonces qué sucede
los triángulos heavy y fbi son
congruentes una vez más entonces el
triángulo g/b
es congruente al triángulo
efe y esto de aquí es por criterio por
criterio
lado lado lado lado lado lado o también
podemos pensarlo como como otro criterio
que ya habíamos platicado también
podemos pensarlo por el criterio ángulo
recto lado hipotenusa si tenemos dos
triángulos rectángulos con un lado en
común y la hipotenusa en común entonces
son triángulos congruentes bueno no
importa cómo lo digamos concluimos que
los triángulos heavy y fb son
congruentes y entonces tenemos que cada
una de sus partes correspondientes es
congruente entonces a partir de aquí
podemos concluir podemos concluir que el
ángulo
efe gv
es congruente al ángulo efe vm al ángulo
f b
entonces este ángulo de acá es igual
este ángulo de acá y de ahí tenemos que
ver
me seca y seca al ángulo a bs a bs y eso
es justo lo que queríamos probar vale
queríamos probar que estaba sobre la
bisectriz del ángulo a b c muy bien
entonces ya tenemos pues 22 resultados
bonitos verdad por un lado tenemos que
si un punto está sobre la bisectriz
entonces ese punto es equidistante de
los lados que forman el ángulo que la
bisectriz corta a la mitad hasta aparece
trabalenguas verdad pero bueno
básicamente cierto en la bisectriz es
equidistante a los lados y también
probamos el regreso probamos que si es
equidistante a los lados entonces está
en la bisectriz